en tout genre ce n'est plus un enfant
non c'est un grand enfant il a les
cheveux bouclés comme un enfant mais il
y des conneries comme un adulte bien
jean salençon est avec nous
[Applaudissements]
c'est là
ces nouveaux sosie mission
spéciale mais j'ai pas mis les lunettes
bleues aujourd'hui c'est vrai mais tout
le reste est parfait oui mais le sipo si
tu m'as
c'est compliqué les enfants sont encore
en coulisses alors pierre gensse et le
faisais pas encore fait le buzz cette
semaine c'est hallucinant en déclarant
que vous m oui toutes les semaines mais
que vous étiez traités comme de la merde
dans la sphère conclu ma loge était les
toilettes de sophie davant il y avait
des rats france télévisions où nous
refuser les motos taxis on était payé
une misère voilà tout ce que vous avez
dit déjà va être un petit peu cash de
turcs h vous étiez payé combien c'est
quoi une misère on n'était pas payé on
était d'effrayer
youpi non après ça on était payé
défrayés pour six émissions
1500 euros à facture à facturation par
émission non non pour toute la journée
alors pour cette émission entre six et
sept émissions alors que ça fait 150 à
200 euros des missions sur internet et
et ce alors est ce qu est ce qu on
refait les choses maintenant domaine on
est honnête ou pas du tout oui c'est
vrai oui on est honnête ou par un oui
avec toi tu fais moi je vous adore ben
forcément j'ai eu la production et j'ai
travaillé un petit peu c'est pas ça les
salaires ont géré moi j'étais payé 1500
euros par jour aux émissions c'était
1500 euros mais effectivement il y avait
12 jours de tournage vous étiez payer
entre 16 et la 1000 euros par mois et
par lé passé oui mais ça si c'est
exactement la même chose ah ben voilà
c'est entre 16 et 20 millions par mois
ce que monsieur annonçant à pernes
misère
même chose c'est-à-dire que par jour de
tournage te payer à facturation 1100
immigrés que douze jours tu comptes à la
diffusion mais en jours de tournage toi
tu travailles et c'était toujours ça
fait entre 15 et 20 millions robe noir
moiré pas douze jours moi je faisais à
peu près 6 mutuelle me dire que c'est
entre 15 et la mine maintenant réserver
des gros mois mémé tu devais dépenser
mais on peut pas dire père jean ont
gagné misère et 20 mille euros par mort
parce que c'était pas vingt mille euros
de salaire c'est est d'effrayer c'était
cette émission est d'effrayer pas
d'effrayer c'est lamine ba tu peux le
mettre dans tous les sens
mission à faire conclut si tu n'achètes
pas tu es viré mon coq wibf je sais pas
ça pour l'argent de façon vous fait ça
pour la gloire elle a vraiment fait ça
pour m'amuser c'est pas l'argent juste à
propos de virer est ce que finalement
vous dit pas tout ce que vous avez dit
cette semaine parce que l' aventure
s'est mal terminée
concernant tu sais pas ce que moi c'est
une fonction je fréquente pourquoi on
travaille énormément julien qu elle que
j'adore je vois j'ai encore vu
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure dans les loges
une maquilleuse que j'adore et qui m'a
dit [ __ ] tu arrêtes à mes raisons de
dire ce que ce que tu as dit parce que
c'est la vérité georges concernant les
rats et c'est oui non mais je suis droit
dans mes bottes j'ai même lu alexandra
morel il ya quelques jours au téléphone
qui est dit mais tu as raison non non tu
sais moi je reçois encore tous ces gens
là à la maison il vient le dîner je fais
des dîners mais son message vous connais
vous balancer sur tout le monde sur
sophie davant il parle d'un accord
proche des jeunes a dit rien sur sophie
j'adore sophie
favier quand même où c'est nouveau ça
c'est depuis une heure et demie avant la
mi-séance à nador et son écoute mais
pourquoi tu veux que je peux tu me
fâcher avec sophie d'un nom alors on en
a on se bat c'est vraiment une copine on
sait pas revu depuis longtemps on
s'envoie des petits messages ça fait un
bout de temps calme à paoua elle
m'apporte n'ont alors pas pour ça non
mais est ce que j'aimerais c'est de
comprendre parce que je vous adore vous
êtes cash mais c'est vrai qu'un cash
sans vous avez été remercié de
l'émission c'est parce que vous aviez
été entre autres à l'anniversaire de son
studio de télévision à temps je
n'apprécie pas la liberté d'expression
si on veut il paraît que vous aviez déjà
reçu pas mal de jeu on va dire
d'avertissement avant puis notamment il
ya eu les faire line renaud quant à
johnny est mort vous avez dit qu'il
devrait la rejoindre leurs jours ne sont
heureusement les chances et demi
les neurones aussi vous saviez que le
jour elle partira enfin la grande fête
non
on ne touche pas à l'inrs non mais mais
ali d'une méchanceté sans nom mais c'est
pourquoi fêter la mort des gens hyper
gens c'est là où tout à tour serait si
et quand on l montréal prend une grande
fête et oui elle écoute c'est comme ça
que ça se fera que c est ce qu est ce
que c'est vrai ou pas il paraît que line
renaud serait intervenu auprès de france
télévisions pour vous faire licencier
mais bien sûr assez bref donc pouvoir
que ça
veut dire que j'ai pas un mot de travers
oui oui bien sûr non mais moi je vais
dire line renaud c'est bon parce qu'il
ya avant-hier j'ai je n'ai connu que
j'étais tout jeune j'ai aucun problème
vis-à-vis de line renaud mais un
consensus était à bord de quel
coût c'était une écoute tu es connu
tirer le luron qu'inconnu coluche cas
que nous tous ces gens là moi c'était
pour moi s'il manque tant que ça quand
est-ce que tu le rejoint j'ai obligé
ambiguïté oui et récemment parce que tu
sais moi j'ai fait pas mal de copains
aussi encore en politique et j'ai dîné
il n'ya pas longtemps avec un monsieur
qui la connaît très bien et il lui a dit
et coups de pierres gens aimeraient
qu'on se réconcilie et c'était avec
l'état et à l'adie lui jamais c'est mon
pire ennemi c'est plutôt flatteur bon
voilà c'est tout elle veut pas se
réconcilier c'est dommage moi c'est une
femme pour qui j'ai de l'affection de
l'admiration
on est bon on est d'accord qu'on a un
peu et vous savez très bien on a un peu
dans la provoc et grichka son son parti
et que vous faites une vidéo sur twitter
en disant igor vient de mourir j'ai
perdu 30 % mon carré d'adressent en ce
moment vous savez que ça va provoquer
vous savez que ça à faire réaliser
jusqu'à c'était vraiment des amis très
proches ah ça m'a vraiment tout le monde
et des amis très jaloux
nous on n'est pas proche portant jetons
se connaît non mais bon tu vois j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup d'amis mais pas moi et
j'en ai pourra que vous êtes ami avec
des petites heures non mais je suis pas
plus amis que ça avec beaucoup de gens
mais la province croit quand j'entends
des gens chez moi qui viennent dit les
trois-quatre fois je pense que c'est des
amis est ce qu'on peut attendre même
reçu quasiment le tout paris depuis
depuis 15 ans alors
qu'il y avait eu quelques extraits de
vous qu'on adore mais encore une fois
moi je le redis ce que je parte sommes
avec vous j'ai tourné au palais viennent
pour un élémentaire mathieu oui je
trouve qu'à ses tout ça je te rends fait
je vous dire la vérité je trouve que
hélas c'est sincère c'est du gâchis pire
gens c'est ça lorsque sur france
télévisions vous avez un regard danse
avec les stars vous voulez d'autres
chaînes vous voulez desserrer vous
voulez danser une star c'est pas de ma
faute ans non mais il ya tellement de
gens qui vous disent qu'un tel
personnage vous avez la collection
bonaparte la vertu grandes collections
mais il vous est cultivé et on a
l'impression que zemmour dieudonné les
phrases sont sophie davant sur sur line
renaud en passant que vous mettez une
baffe dans pile toujours c'est vrai ce
que tu dis tu vois l'histoire de l'hymne
ça fait ça fait maintenant deux ans donc
c'est bon c'est fini j'ai compris sophie
davant j'ai rien n'est jamais rien et
contrat il n'y a pas de souci quant à
france télévisions 6e pas les gens comme
moi bah tant pis pour eux ils ont viré
tout le monde pas son temps on peut dire
que c'est mon côté des eyquems doit
faire conclut je sais bien que c'est pas
les amis mais quand même ouais tu sais
on a affaire conclue ce pour cela la fin
de l'année j'avais dit qu ils nous
traitaient un peu comme de la merde mais
cet écart est un peu la vérité sophie
davant madame sophie davant elle se
permettait d'arriver en moto taxi nous
on nous avait refusé ça au bout d'un an
parce que ça soit disant que ça coûtait
trop cher on était payé au lance-pierre
des sommes ridicules on n'avait même pas
une loge vous saviez ce que c'était que
notre loge c'étaient les toilettes ou
sophie davant allez allez faire ces voix
là à le connaître si je peux dire et il
y avait un petit frigo avec des souris
et des rats
je te jure que c'est vrai mais la menoua
ppm p j'adore la prod mais cyril à sa
loge et puis nous on aime tous les
chroniqueurs on n'a pas de l'inla écoute
moi quand je suis ici je suis hyper bien
c'est la classe c est passer une autre
vidéo aussi pour montrer à quel point je
suis sûr tu es sincère mais à quel point
tu es maladroit et je me dis est ce que
c'est de la maladresse salève angeli
pour faire le buzz ou est ce que
vraiment tu te rends pas compte c'est
quand tu parles
accusé d antisémitisme et voilà ce que
tu réponds pas ému quand vous parlez de
tout ça j'ai l'impression que vous en
faites vous avez de la peine malgré tout
2 je sais pas si c'est de ce qui se
passe de ce qu'on a dit sur vous bien
sûr j'ai de la peine
c'est horrible comme avant on vous
traite d'antisémite
les trucs
merde
une mezouza maison j'ai de mes
meilleures amies c'est jean michel cohen
julliard était un copain michael kramer
on va tous mes amis et en depuis 24
heures aux tigres dessau prix c'est
horrible et ben moi je vous sens sincère
c'est à dire que j'étais sincère c'est
pour ça c'est bien glacé combat
alors en un [ __ ] mois pierre-jean vous
avez eu un soucis de santé oui il ya
quelques années de ça d'accord vous avez
vu beaucoup souffrir beaucoup d'accords
et en souffrent autant comme on peut
être dur avec certaines personnalités
comme ça dana beaucoup plus avancé que
vous comment on doit rester avoir un peu
plus d'humilité que ça et d'essayer de
rester tout le temps dans la provocation
de provoquer à droite à gauche par
rapport à la grippe à paramé aura plein
de gens par rapport parce que vous
n'avez pas quand même une très très dur
de la salle on le remarque je laisserais
passer un peu du gâchis ou est-ce que
franchement je trouve excellent
excellent elle là je connais pas
beaucoup et je connais pas beaucoup mais
c'est vrai que quand on a vécu des
choses difficiles dans la vie on doit
être un peu plus conciliant avec book
mal alors ils te répondent écoute tu
sais moi je suis quelqu'un de très
gentil bouddha peut-être trop gentil
d'ailleurs pour faire de la télévision
c'est sûrement sûrement je pense parce
que la force d'être gentil tu en as
marre de prendre des claques et des
clash sûrement vexé par av je pense que
vous en avez aussi pris quelques unes à
une époque je pense que la télévision
n'est pas fait pour des gens gentils et
la télévision elle est fait pour des
gens qui sont qui sont là media luna
mettez à tous les animateurs
il faut vraiment il faut vraiment avoir
une carapace je suis pas comme ça je
suis trop impulsif je le sais moi la
télévision je vais ça pour marié genre
frais et j'en ferai pas c'est pas très
grave je ferai d'autres choses la preuve
ça fait un an et demi je suis parti de
la télévision j'arrête pas de venir à
des buzz woody
qu'aujourd'hui parce que jamais urgents
mais c'est là votre ami comme je parle
beaucoup pire janvier on passe notre
temps à taper sur les gens qui sont
langue de bois 10 juin qui joue un rôle
qui sont pas naturels on a quelqu'un qui
dise qu'ils pensent parfois de façon un
peu maladroite
s'écoute et se trouveront le dézinguer
moi je trouve il mérite pas ça il a son
caractère c'est un personnage est bon le
prix moyen
par exemple par exemple reçu de l'argent
c'est un point de vue sur le point de
vue des lgbt par exemple donc vous êtes
homosexuel vous dites que vous êtes un
peu le porte parole notre quoi que vous
voulez défendre la cause homo sapiens
oui et finalement on vous retrouve au
meeting de zemmour en première place et
scapa une incohérence là dessus sachant
que je n'ai ni d'ailleurs bien mais vous
êtes au meeting de zemmour de là ça n'a
rien à voir et c'est pourquoi aviez vous
savez pour les montants et les dîners
avec l'épisode de la semaine on a
coutume avait il m'avait invité j'y suis
allé je suis pas retournée on verra
nulle part ailleurs donc ne sera
d'accord avec son seyant il ya
énormément de choses je suis pas du tout
abattu il a répondu pourquoi tout père
jean il va m'aider je suis enfant que
derrière ça va être analysé les photos
me souvenir exil et aux jambes et aux
évangiles après les appels au call of
the bell récisé mans parce qu'on vous
aide et moi je vous aime profondément
lamouchi mais je me dis quand vous dites
des trucs justement sur line renaud ou
vont de toute façon vous ne pouvez pas
tout ni revenir là là mais pourquoi est
ce qu'ils disent à sarlabous entre ainsi
par la majorité des gens donc dans ces
cas là il faut s'abstenir ce que c'est
bon c'est bien le dire comme ça à mes
deux chats raison tu as raison c'est si
vous avez des regrets quand même ou pas
oui bien sûr sur quoi par exemple sur ma
sur l'une rodo j'aurais pas dû le dire
c'est la bonne plaisir de le dire bah
voilà j'aurai besoin lire parce que je
suis aimé j'avais bu deux bouteilles de
rosé
revenir
c'était bien et je ne pensais pas que
mon opinion pouvait intéresser la france
entière oui j'ai l'impression d'être
repris à chaffoteaux à dieu donnez vous
la regretter bien entendu je l'avais
fait j'ai pas moins qu'il ait fait les
bons choix avec tout et regrette hureaux
je vais trop foot en selle tu attends
mais on n'est pas meilleurs oui à propos
de regrets parce que ça qu on en a
beaucoup parlé il ya quelques mois nous
chez closer vous nous avez pas vous êtes
chez clover est à fait il va me dire
également destin qu'est ce que vous
pensez méritée nous avait fait par nos
jours n'est pas français j'ai été là
j'ai eu ce que vous avez dit à l'époque
était hyper contradictoire c'est bon
mais je n'ai pas là et j'ai d'ailleurs
j'ai pigé j'ai rien ne jugez pas
évidemment du zéro j'ai rien du tout à
part ce que c'était difficile à prouver
mais vous souvenez canon mais j'ai pas
fais vraiment mais d'où vient qu'il doit
bien qu'il ait cash pourquoi j'avais
fait la fête et on dirait show qu'ils
ont fait je te dis vite pas je leur ai
dit voilà comment je m'en suis pas
arrêté de parler des rats parce que
france télévisions a été construits en
zone inondable et dès lors il n'a rien à
voir avec la scène c'est pas le sujet
principal
et bordeaux nautique au pérou toujours
de dresde a porté par des 5e ou 6e moi
j'aime bien me gratter toi ça n'est que
veut dire année
alors ludivine des baux et ensuite on va
quand même écouter parce que vous sortez
un single mais attends j'ai sorti deux
singles
pas été vraiment c'est mon premier
admirateur et je lui en suis très
reconnaissant
rubis
il tenta stick à lèvres tous
fonctionnaires ont rien quand même
[Rires]
concert
réunir chez toi à quoi tu verras jamais
revenir avec les écouteurs à linge
allusion pour tous les budgets dîner
chez les rockets n'ont gérons bien vous
inviter à
s'entraîner mais qui soutenait même
genre
vraiment parce qu'il faut qu'on aille
car aurait serré dernière le figure le
figaro récemment enfin papier sur vous
aviez fait une une énorme
vente aux enchères dont parce que vous
étiez surendettés à la mort et je
voulais savoir si c'était totalement
faux j'ai pris des avocats si ridicule
exactement donc c'est pas la peine
c'est quoi
[Musique]
je vais faire
je suis ton cul je
te ferai un petit bourg des argales un
blu ray barona
il est venu répondre à toutes les
questions à tout le buzz je vous promets
que je pense qu'à pas de m'échanger ce
garçon-là proches procédera ce sera en
plus de la musique manger téléphone
merci pierre jean salençon d'avoir été
avec nous vraiment merci à pierre jean
c'était un bonheur de pouvoir et c'est
un bonheur de vous
tous merci beaucoup merci que l'argent
merci merci encore
il n'y a pas de match et ce monsieur y a
pas de magie